pop
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
ouvrez cet intérêt dans l'émoi simple
est non ouvrez ce secrétaire et donnez
moi
cette laine je ne veux pas d'où venez
vous ah c'est autre chose maintenant
oui c'est autre chose je vous demande de
vous mener je vais vous dit vous
regardiez en ce moment pour voir la
figure que vous me fais pas mon ami vous
me plaisez mieux dans votre état
audibert pas où irons-nous mon dieu si
vous perdez toute mesure pour un méchant
billets que le premier venu peut-être
m'adresser ouvrez ce secrétaire et
donnez moi cette lettre mais elle est là
moi
vous devez penser que des scènes comme
celle ci si elle se renouveler
fréquemment me détacherai bien vite de
vous je ne pourrais pas je vous en
prévient subi un interrogatoire chaque
fois que j'aurai bill keller d'où venez
vous tâchez nous d'être logique au moins
je vous le conseille il n'est pas
probable que je quitte quelqu'un est
qu'en rentrant chez moi je trouve un
mode nuit ouvraient secrétaire et donnez
moi cette lettre vous plaisantez n'est
ce pas je n'en ai pas laid vous me
soupçonner alors c'est plus probable où
il voulait vous exigez vous me commander
ça très bien
à
hahaha
ouvrez vous même alors amassé doux et à
les ouvrir
quand on a commencé on va jusqu'au bout
on montre qu'on est un homme fallait
bien qu est ce que vous allez faire si
vous ramassez ses clés du bout des
doigts le bout des doigts
ce n'est pas moi qui ne le regretterai
ce sera vous reprenez ok sauf vous savez
qu est ce qui augmente le mal est en
progrès nous en avertit et kalman
mettait bien aperçu déjà vous me
surveiller que je riais touba de la
peine que vous vous donnez s'il
musulmans jusqu'ici cependant il n'y
avait rien à dire c'était de la jalousie
mais une jalousie admirable qui fut la
flamme propre du terme
vous venez de passer à d'autres la
jalousie stupide grossière brutal qui
nous blessent profondément que nous ne
pardonnerons jamais deux fois
recommencerez vous
clotilde recommencerez vous non
clotilde quoi mon ami vous m'aimez au
aujourd'hui moi qui ai vous désirez me
voir heureux je voulais montrer assez je
crois j'ai peur de tous ces jeunes gens
qui vous entourent et qui tourne autour
de vous vous avez bientôt je cause avec
l'un avec l'autre comme autour des mines
c'est plus seulement qui m'a parlé vous
ne vous rappelez personne que vous
auriez encourager qu'on s'en vouloir
et qui se serait cru autorisé à vous
écrire ouvrez secrétaire est devenu mois
7,7 l'entrée de mon amie madame doyer à
beaulieu la plus vertueuse des femmes
sous ses airs des rapports je sais ce
que mes cris pauline et je serai la
première à vous le dire quand vous ne me
demanderez plus clôture après vous être
raisonnable plus que jamais la tête et
tranquille la tête et tranquille et le
cas aussi donc c'est à moi que le tireur
ait pensé à nous dites vous qu une
sottise bien vite comme il est qu'elle
est souvent irréparables
ne vous laissez pas aller à ce coup des
aventures qui fait aujourd'hui tant de
victimes résister clôture résisté en ne
restant fidèle vous rester digne et
honorable dans le jour où vous mettront
peut rien prenez garde pas là mon mari
l'espoir est bien que c'était là donc
j'attendrai allez-vous parler vos petits
bouts quand vous êtes ensemble
le tonnerre ne vous arrêterez pas
c'était donc rentrer oui j'ai fait
rentrer les auteurs depuis quelque temps
il me semble lorsqu'un de ses amis et
l'acte pour être montrées et le recevoir
je terminais quelque chose qu'est ce que
tu as dit ont donc vu on la rencontre
pas aisément
il m'a fait dire de revenir aujourd'hui
petit que je t'accompagne tu nous
gênerait merci comment vas-tu pas man et
war of me sens bien galien en ce moment
qu'est ce qui ne va pas je travaille
beaucoup et les mains santé sans ça on
se repose alors il faut du temps et de
l'argent pour se reposer de l'argent tu
en gagnes je le reçois d'une main je le
donne de l'autre c'est amusant ça c'est
amusant quand on naît garçon tu viens tu
as fini de te plaindre à crois tu que tu
m'intéresses monsieur lafon est une
phase plaisir auquel propos doute ces
lamentations tu manges bien tu dors bien
je ne connais pas de mari qu'on doive
être comme toi tu travailles sans doute
du travail tout le monde travaille si
j'étais à ta place je serais quatre fois
plus de besogne et j'en parlerai 40 fois
moins
elle est super ma femme on ne sait pas
on cherche ce que c'est qu'une maison
comme la mienne ou les charges
augmentent tous les ans et où les
habitudes deviennent plus coûteuse tous
les jours qu à continuer ce mois parler
un peu je ne vous ai pas déranger tout à
l'heure assieds toi et tu prends ton
ouvrage puisque tu es si laborieuse
jette un coup d'oeil sur les culottes de
tes enfants ça ne fera pas maintenant
ces pauvres petits ont toujours leurs
postérieurs à l'est mais tu le verras
comme pas assez
la femme de chambre est là pour ça nous
sommes logés aussi modestement possible
je paye très cher pour vivre dans une
prison
les domestiques aujourd'hui ne se
contente plus de gaz ce sont des impôts
et manque il leur faudra nous dînons
envie de le souvent presque tous les
jours mais ma femme naturellement veut
être habillé comme toutes ces dames
est ce qu'on économise d'à côté on le
dépense de l'eau continue
voilà la vente à ce sujet sensible je me
dis pas manger mieux faire un bon report
de work un mauvais chez moi rohff une
estampe houriez parlant des choses plus
agréables
tu es célibataire mon cher la faune et
bien crois moi restent eux est ce votre
avis barrez vous ne vous mariez pas ça
ne regarde que vous peux tu être plus
aimables que ma femme et écouter ce que
je vais te mettrais volontiers en fait
de grandes démarche en ce moment pour
moi des démarches qui en valent la peine
quand moi ça c'est mon oncle mon oncle
jean baptiste le membre de l'institut
que ma situation ne satisfait pas depuis
longtemps
il veut que je rentre dans
l'administration des finances
il va là des amis la plupart me
connaissent ces messieurs se sont
entendus pour me trouver une recette
particulière
voilà une position qui te conviendrait
que tu remplirait à tournai et où tu
n'aurais plus besoin de personne je ne
marche pas mal en ce moment je suis très
apprécié et maintenant par mes sociétés
linsi écrit pas un chiffre qui ne me
passe sous les yeux mais collaboration
était recherché un aux intérêts des
moniteurs à grotte accord agricole
louis où je lance un pétard de 30 ans et
ça me fait connaître j'accepte tout ce
qui se présente mis mon oncle ne
l'entend pas de cette oreille car il
trouve qu'à mon âge avec une femme et
des enfants
on doit cette fait sa place quelque part
et il a raison il a peut-être raison je
suis un mathématicien je ne suis pas un
économiste je suis
autre chose je te dirais entre nous que
mon petit ouvrage mais qu'on dise de
considérations morales sur le budget ont
été très recherchées
ces livres là ne s'adresse qu'à un
public de choix ne s'achète pas comme
des romans mais on a vendu de mes
considérations à l'heure qu'il est 119
exemplaires il me sort 18 il ya un
exemplaire qui ne se retrouvent pas on
l'a peut être devant lui je voyais tout
une sphère nouvelle pour moi un filon à
exploiter
occupes toi de ta recette d'abord c'est
plus sûr après tu vois ce que voudra je
vais chercher de mon côté à te donner un
coup de pouce quart de ton bien mon nom
que s'est avancé dans cette affaire et
il entend être seul avec ses amis à
déterminer il nous semble lorsqu'un
membre de l'académie des sciences
morales et politiques consentent à
solliciter lorsqu'il sollicite pour son
neveu lorsque ce neveu est quelque chose
que le gouvernement n'a pas été abordée
keystone amis
les places ne sont pas toujours à sa
disposition je sais il le pourra
prochainement
10 - e il est clair qu'on te propose une
recette à paris apparu a entendu ma
femme ne pourrait pas tous trois
provinces à d'al ahly cette lettre
qu'est ce qu'elles disent eux-mêmes
louvre lie tu verras c'est pauline qui
m'écrit ma chérie tu vas recevoir si ce
n'est déjà fait une invitation de madame
simpson pour son grand val
du 25 ton amour crois pas tu es en
bonnes mains et n'a pas eu à souffrir
j'ai prononcé ton nom on la saisit au
vol en me disant qu'on te connaissais
bien que tu étais une fort jolie
personne et qu'on serait charme et de
t'avoir un ces soirées te voilà de la
maison je suis bien sûr que mon ami te
plaira et que vous vous entendrez très
bien ensemble
adam elle n'est plus de la première
jeunesse
tu me diras large que tu lui donnes et
je te dirai celui qu'elle a ça n'empêche
pas au bal décolleté avec tous ces
diamants l'ex belle madame simpson ne
fasse encore illusion des bras des yeux
une façon de sourire que je n'ai vu que
telle et telle indulgence
elle ne se choque de rien elle comprend
toutes les faiblesses il n'est pas de
légèreté si grande qu'elle soit il ne
lui paraissent intéressantes ou
excusable
c'est une véritable bande am et qu'elle
a une chance elle ne se choque de rien
elle comprend toutes les agressions
il n'est pas de légèreté si grande
qu'elle soit je n'aime pas beaucoup la
lettre de pauline à votre amie madame
est bien la conséquence tu vois tu vois
je connais cette de madame simpson
il court de drôles d'histoires sur son
compte
madame simpson a une réputation
déplorable tu entends un content je ne
veux pas te mener dans une maison
compromettantes à votre place n'est pas
là je vous assure au milieu de femmes
déconsidère et bien ça doit être frappé
de voir que la faune et moins nous
pensons exactement de même
ce que tu voudras si nous n'allons pas
chez les malades si nous sommes
d'ailleurs voilà tout mais à l'avenir tu
attendras pour parler de certaines
choses que nous soyons seul je n'ai pas
l'habitude de consulter des étrangers je
suis puni la faune un étranger mais il
ya tant de la brouille avec l'om mais
c'est toi
depuis que tu es ici qu'il dirige bien
inutilement je m'en vais au voyage
qu'est ce que tu fais aujourd'hui ce qui
ne plaira ou dit non nous ce soir n'en
sais rien comme tu me réponds même gêné
avec un homme corps et leur est
désobligeant tu tiens donc bien se bat
s'agit pas de cheval j'avais déjà oublié
n'ai pas 20 ans je crois pour me
préoccuper de la balle de plus ou de
moins quand tu viens tu cries tu frappes
sur ta femme sur le plus petit écart
pourrait elle quand tu nous entends dray
serait une bien triste idée il ne bien
fondé de notre intérieur jeu plus
honteux peux tu ne te venge donc tu en
trouveras beaucoup de mal comme je
grogne pendant trois secondes et quand
tu être décidé quelque chose il faut
toujours y arriver qu'est ce qui est le
maître
ici je pense beaucoup à cette recette
qui c'est une grosse affaire pour nous
et qui devrait te préoccuper davantage
allons clotilde bien raisonnablement
rapide je réussisse
nous verrons j'étais titre n'est ce pas
les titres ou cinq ans je suis appuyée
par des hommes étant non pas l'affluence
est ce grand patronage de l'institut ne
te paraît pas décisif tu ne veux pas que
je m'emmêle tu as peut-être tort
qu'est-ce que tu ferais mille choses qui
ne coûte rien à une femme et
ça qu on se promenant je mettrai toutes
mes amies en campagne pauli d'abord elle
tu estimes tu embolie elle voudrait bien
que son mari thomas semble poli qu'il
est très lié avec madame simpson lors
est intéressé à d'autres ménages a tout
fait rire quand tu ne veux pas aller
chez madame simpson
merci coq bien nous elle retrouve qu'il
ya plus à paris elle a tous les jours
deux ou trois ministres à cet art elle
tord effet dîné avec que tu leur aurait
exposé la situation bien tranquillement
d'égal à égal en fumant de gros cigare
comme tu les aimes et le jour où tu es
les hommes compétents sera venu te dire
nous sommes désolés la place était
promise tu leur aurait répondu je le
sais bien
j'ai ma nomination dans ma poche voilà
comme je comprends les as fait tu as
peut être raison l'écoutent
ne précipitons rien si je vois un moment
donné que les choses tournent mal et que
mes relations suffisent pas nous
essaierons alors utiliser les tiennent
quand il voudra
tu sais que c'est ma devise avec toi
alors vraiment mon nom j'emmène la faune
bien le gars de tulle je garde ma
patiente mais il m'a vu son hymne c'est
toujours rire tu le traite mal ce pauvre
la faune qui est aimable et oblige on
aimerait tant qu'un homme embrasse à
avec un départ de m
alors ne m'accompagne pas facile mais
c'est aussi ce désagréable comme dit ma
femme tu ne sais pas ce que c'est être
avec une famille des enfants on les aime
beaucoup
on ne pense qu'à elle on se fait tous
bex il vous manquait et ça n'empêche pas
car moment de les envoyer à tous les dix
ans
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
mais tu sais un peu que de prudence il
faut te vois mon mari serait entré une
minute plus tôt j'étais perdu vous vous
êtes moquer de moi pendant sa avec cet
électron pas à lutter chichin de me la
montrer tout de suite je pensais qu'elle
ne vous ferait pas plaisir je ne me suis
pas trompé et puis c'était un piège que
je vous tendait je voulais savoir si
vous vous arrêteriez attend pour une
autre fois pour une autre fois
précisément etes-vous perte de mon avis
eh ben je suis dans vos suppositions et
a dit je veux bien faire quelque chose
pour vous quoi que vous ne le méritez
guerre mon mari ouvre toutes mes lettres
toutes sans exception je les ai préféré
ainsi vous voilà tranquille de ce côté
maintenant à ses yeux et courageuse que
je vous en prie en cause d'un chauffage
ce n'est ce pas mon mari d'une part ou
de l'autre c'est peut-être beaucoup dans
le même jeu voulez-vous me dire quelle
mouche vous pique est ce que signifie
cette jalousie qui pourrait devenir
inquiétante
ça vous a pris tout d'un coup aux
environs du 15 janvier
j'ai une raison pour me rappeler cette
date quelle raison y en a une ça suffit
vous n'allez pas maintenant vous arrêter
sur chaque nous parler un peu je vous
écoute
d'où venez vous je vous demande pardon
mon ami j'avais oublié que vous m'aviez
fait cette question plusieurs fois et
que je n'irai pas encore répondu j'avais
un rôle et vous ne vous emportez pas
avec ma modiste on en rencontre que fort
peu de messieurs je vous assure vous me
permettez bien d'aller de temps en temps
j'aime à me disent maintenant fait ce
que je désire et répondez moi que je
sache un peu quelles sont mes torts
envers vous j'aurais toujours bien de la
peine à me trouver
je ne vous voit plus à bas et que faites
vous donc en ce moment parce que je ne
suis pas là
tant pis pour vous si vous perdez en
discussion et encore elle un temps que
nous pourrions employés plus
agréablement
mais j'ai attendu toute cette semaine la
semaine dernière aussi
et la précédente encore taratata et
pourquoi pas qu un nom et quand cela
serait quand je vous aurais manqué
parole non pas une fois mais ça en fois
la belle raison pour supposer tout de
suite des horreurs qu'elle ne dispose
toujours de moi comme je le voudrais
être que je ne dépends pas de tout le
monde ici je suis marié je n'avais pas
l'air de le savoir
il y a autre chose je veux que vous me
disiez ce qu'il y a il me semble que
notre liaison plus intéressant que vous
souhaitez du nouveau et que vous l'avez
peut-être déjà rencontré nous en sommes
à ce moment où commencent les mensonges
les mauvais tours les petites familles
ne sait bien pas bien mon ami à quel
moment toutes ces belles choses
commencent vous êtes mieux renseigner
comme honnête je vous demande des fêtes
quelque chose d'honnête de précis de
positive que je puisse anéanti d'un seul
jour quand est ce qui se passe dans
votre imagination que voulez-vous que je
vous dise elle ne me paraît pas bien
folichon de votre imagination ni remplie
de souvenirs aux couleurs de rose cette
date du 15 janvier qui vous est resté si
précises et bien cette date elle m'a
frappé moi aussi
convenez que nous ne nous a pas frappés
du tout je m'en vais vous avoir troublé
avec cette date qui signifie quelque
chose pour moi et qui pour vous ne veut
rien je fais bien des remarques depuis
mais quel bien des observations l
observation
je n'ai rien se sont tenus du nuances
mais les nuances
il ne faut pas jouer avec les nuances
vous avez bien changé ma chère clotilde
ou son rejoindre compte
vous me voyez d'abord c'est désobligeant
je vous trouve distraite fort souvent
efforts souvent aussi embarrassé je vois
que vous me cacher ce que vous faites je
tremble alors de vous interroger
il vous arrive aussi quelquefois de vous
contredire mais tu me parler de gens
d'un tout autre monde que le vôtre et
que vous savez parker du jour au
lendemain comme ans c'est vous
maintenant qu'il me racontait les
scandales j'avais eu le plaisir
jusqu'ici tous les apprendre vous
opinions politiques ne sont plus les
mêmes
celui-là qui vous écoutent sérieusement
mes opinions politiques voulaient dire
que je suis réactionnaire j'ai pas varié
a pour cela vous avez raison je suis une
bonne réaccélère j'aime l'autre la
tranquillité les principes bien établis
mais on admettant que mes opinions
politiques se fussent modifié il me
semble que vous auriez moins que
personne à vous employez vous ne faites
pas fini mon nouveau vous êtes démocrate
tu ne montes aujourd'hui qu'il engage à
rouler dans tous les partis
vous êtes un libre penseur je crois que
vous vous entendriez très bien avec une
maîtresse qui n'auraient pas de religion
qu'est ce que viens de vous dire mon
avis je vous prie m'a parlé d'une
position qu'ils désirent obtenir et
qu'on va sans doute lui donner ça ne
vous a pas intéresser beaucoup dit gros
coup comme vous me diriez pas du tout
comment trouvez-vous marc hé bien il
vous paraît pas soucieux et fatigué non
parce je ne sais pas pourquoi je vous
parle d'adolphe pour l'affection voulu
porter croit vos intérêts
voilà où je voulais en venir vous savez
que mon mari attend une position
il l'attend du gouvernement cela va sans
dire lorsqu'on désire une position c'est
bien au gouvernement qu'il faut
s'adresser
et vous croyez que j'irai critiqué le
gouvernement au moment même où il
s'occupe de nous maintenant ne ferais ça
c'est toujours si bavard un homme si
maladroit aussi ingrat des femmes jamais
voulez vous que je vous dise mon avis
vous avait obéi à fort ville un calcul
vous avez couru peut-être qu'en allant
de l'avant vous découvririez quelque
chose mais vous ne savez rien et vous le
saurez rien parce qu'il n'ya rien à
savoir maintenant écoutez bien ceci vous
devez vous dire que je ne suis pas libre
quand j'ai une maison à conduire et des
amis a conservé la bagatelle ne vient
qu'après son j'ai bien aussi que la plus
petite incartade de votre part peuvent
compromettre et simon henry apprenez
quelque chose me précipiter je ne sais
où je ne veux pas vous m'entendez bien
je ne veux pas vous retrouver comme
aujourd'hui nous on m'apporte plantes et
gesticulant et prêt à tout avaler quand
je reviens bien tranquillement le schéma
couturière
mais qu'est ce qui vous prend maintenant
d'où venez vous je viens de vous le dire
non et chez votre maudit ce toucher
votre couturière que vous êtes à lui
pourquoi répondait elle chez votre mode
10 toucher votre couturière que vous
êtes allé c'était serré de la haine vous
satisfait
maintenant il faut vous lever et vous en
aide non si plus tard tout de suite mais
quelle affaire vous presse aucune rien à
garder moi c'est impossible
si mon mari revenait qu'il vous trouve à
temps par ici il pourrait se pencher
sérieusement à l'eau soyez raisonnable
et dites moi dieu vous parlerez mois une
autre fois
créative est-ce qu'il ya encore je
rentre chez moi
rentrez chez vous vous n'avez jeunes
faisant la pêche à vous savez leur à peu
près la journée n'est pas encore finie
où elle ne commence pas non vous n'avez
que votre chapeau à m ce n'est pas grand
chose je vous voyais venir jean drèze
était bien étonné si peu de vos
histoires s'était terminée autrement
mettez votre chapeau voulez-vous soit
c'est la seule bonne idée que vous et
lisieux il est bien juste que j'en
profite
allez vous en vous me suivez
je vous suis dans un instant dans un
instant et partez donc à total à tout à
l'heure
[Applaudissements]
madame natale et adèle de neymar de
fonds auprès des banques tout droit
sortie d'audi
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
je suis bien
oui la dame très bien très bien
waller et 3h bientôt bada vrai tout ce
qu'il me faut sur cette terre tout ce
que madame prend d'habitude ses clés son
carnet sa boîte de poudre de riz on
avait moi madame ne reviendra pas
aujourd'hui c'est possible c'est
probable pourquoi je crois que monsieur
à son dîner l'économie s'il ne le montre
pas pour un empire eh bien j'ai remarqué
que madame passé ce jour là chez une
amie de pensions que le mari de madame
ne voit jamais vous écouter lorsque l'on
dit je n'écoute pas nos madame je saisis
seulement quelques mots au passage
j'avais prévenu madame que mon frère je
le connais votre frère vous désirez
sortir c'est bien sûr mais si madame
madame ne voit plus rien a recommandé
non que la cuisinière ou s'éloigner avec
monsieur met à sa disposition quand il
rentrera sabine oui madame ne fait pas
que j'allais me chercher une voiture
c'est inutile je retrouverai une sur mon
chemin au revoir madame dans play
l'afl et madame très bien entendu 3 1 il
ne m'a pas vue depuis fort longtemps
il sait que c'est aujourd'hui le dîner
des économistes je devais m'attendre
quelques bourrasques de cet art est ce
que madame décide à les ouvrir à dell je
me suis pour personne si c'était
monsieur là où madame je vous ai dit
pour personne je ne reçois pas monsieur
lafon plutôt qu'un autre
laissez vos portes ouvertes que
j'entende ce qu'on vous dire s'il
s'agissait d'une affaire pour mon mari
vous feriez asseoir et je viendrai ces
comprimés
voilà voilà pas très bien j'ai eu tort
d'une femme pressée je serais parti à
l'heure qu'il est on n'aurait pas
ennuyer
ah oui c'est bien lui vous pouvez pas
manquer une si belle occasion par le
monde a mis par la question de la
domestique
je crois qu'il demande à adele où je
suis il a juste comment at elle le
laisse entre élus ya ma foi il vient
est-ce qu'il va se reposer ici
or les hommes quand nous les aimons plus
voilà comme ils se conduisent avec nous
c'est bien je vois bien qu'il n'ya
personne
je vais à temps attendre quoi parce que
madame viennent de sortir ensemble
monsieur at il dit à quelle heure il
rentrerait chez lui je sais seulement
que madame ne rentrera pas elle dîne en
ville avec monsieur son monsieur de ce
digne de son côté madame des siens allez
à vos affaires mademoiselle jeu voilà de
quoi écrire je les soins monsieur ce
n'est pas moi qui commet ici je ne peux
pas mettre monsieur à la fin
je suis entré je ne sais pas pourquoi je
suis entré c'est encore une sortie ce
que j'ai fait
il faut il faut me calmer et prendre mon
parti qu'une séparation nécessaire on ne
peut pas conserver à paris de m as un
peu comme d'hab c'est pas possible
plus elle est convenable et moi on la
conserve
j'aurai une explication avec claudine
une explication sanglant ce sera plus
gentille ma part et je la quitterais
définitivement nous je m'agite je cours
je la cherche à droite par auquel
n'échappe à bon chat quoi bon qu'est ce
que j'apprends pas non plus elle est la
maîtresse de ce monsieur mercier
c'est clair comme le jour depuis quand l
avantage un jeune savoir pourquoi je me
demande bien pourquoi elle ne l'est
peut-être pas ce qu'une consolation
mais qu'est ce que je vais faire si
adolf était là au moins nous aurions
fini la journée ensemble
c'est vrai que quand le coeur me
manquait que clotilde hesme a mis sens
dessus dessous c'est encore avec son
mari que je me trouve le mieux je me
sens moins seule la position d'adolphe
me console un peu de la mienne elle est
moins bonne certainement elle est moins
bonne si clotilde nouvelle loi revient
après tout elle advient grands travaux
vers son mari je suis bien fort pour
juger sévèrement de 58 quand je me mets
à la place de son oreille quelle
désolation
je me trouve tout d'un coup isolé sans
un lien la mort dans l'âme devant une
situation des plus vulgaires et que je
vais creuser indéfiniment a les hommes
ne sont guère heureux célibataires ou
cocu il ya bien peu de choix
ampli je me montre je saurai toujours ce
qu'il me veut
je
comment vous êtes chez vous et bien
qu'est ce qu'il ya d'étrange à ce que je
sois chez moi l'étrange c'est que vous
vous y trouviez vous quand je condamne
ma porte et qu'on vous le dit sur tous
les tons voilà comme vous me remercier
de mon indulgence vous ne savez plus que
faire pour me déplaire et je me laisse
aller chaque fois me pardonner ces motos
sont recommençons pas je vous en prie
pas de scène aujourd'hui pas de sel je
m'y prêterai pas d'ailleurs aviez vous
la raison au moins un prétexte quelques
découvertes bien terrible et que vous ne
pouviez pas garder plus longtemps
j'ai craint que je vous la vous que vous
ne puissiez souffrent c'est très
gracieux votre part vous avez vu vous
être inséré allez vous vous sortez
il me semble que je sors n'ai pas
l'habitude de me promener avec un
chapeau dans mon appartement
ne vous êtes pas et c'est suis en retard
on décide en rien qu'est ce que ça veut
dire que je pensais que nous ignorions
ce ensemble si je suis toujours l'ami de
pension ni pour vous ni pour personne
j'ai réfléchi que ces escapades dans les
restaurants arrêt toutes sortes
d'inconvénients elle m'entraîne dans les
mensonges qui vous révolte que je ne
veux pas continuer est-ce que je n'ai
pas reste ne me demandez pas ce que j'en
pense - voler haut je m'attends à tout
est toujours la plus sage en a pas de
déception de cette manière asseyez vous
je vous en prie et cause ont bien
affectueusement pas temps de causer à un
autre jour demain si vous voulez demain
je vous attendrai ayant encore quelque
chose au dernier moment qui vous
empêchera de venir aux fusées demain à
votre aise ça me convient parfaitement
je ne suis jamais pressé de me trouver
avec des gens mécontents et désagréable
mais c'est l'amour qui m'ont appelé nuit
à plaignez vous je vous le conseille on
voit bien que vous n'êtes pas ma place
je me morfonds je me désespère de mon
côté pendant que vous galopait l'autre
[Rires]
c'est que cette expression
admettons ce qui est possible que je me
sois un peu refroidie avec vous croyez
vous ramène une femme en agissant comme
vous le faites au lard selon
perpétuellement c'est tout le contraire
karine la fatigue impatiente et on lui
donne des idées
l'hôtel était à mille lieues
allez faire un petit voyage
oui fait un petit voyage absenté vous
six mois n'est pas le dire une
séparation à ce moment vous conviendrait
fort bien et vous n'en seriez que plus
agréable à votre retour le craignent
rien ton côté je ne suis pas une femme
qui oublie facilement vous me
retrouverez exact - voulez-vous
non on ne voulait pas ne pourriez pas
vous absenter six mois lorsque votre
maîtresse voulu demander qu'elle verrait
là de l'autre par une véritable malle
attachement où allez-vous c'est tout ce
que vous trouvez à me répondre
où allez vous jeter si sûr que vous ne
feriez cette question je l'attends
depuis que vous êtes là elle vous j'aime
nul non vous serez bien avancé n'est ce
pas quand vous saurez où ou d'où je
viens où je vais qu'est ce qui
m'empêcherait de vous dire je vais là et
d'aller ailleurs
je poursuivrai à suivez moi je vous y
regarde ça vous a si bien réussi
jusqu'ici prenez garde je suis très
faible avec vous tout à fait je tiens
compte de tout de l'état où je vous vois
des moments que nous avons vécu ensemble
mais ne vous croyez pas le droit d'en
abuser
je fais ce qui me plaît et ça ne regarde
personne comme mon mari nous me tromper
chi chi québec
apprenez que les soupçons ne suffisent
pas et que pour accuser une femme
il faut avoir la preuve entre les mains
vous êtes toile existants la femme
véritablement coupable un galant tonnes
sait ce qu'il lui reste à faire
il la quitte oui c'était copie
dites donc si vous savez seulement
lequel se serait bien aise de connaître
ce donjon que je fatigue peut-être des
poursuites et qui me faisait plus clair
de son bonheur forcer à vous dire ce que
j'aurai toujours voulu vous cacher
j'avais une grande pause j'avais la
marge des enfants intérieur adorable
j'ai voulu plus j'ai voulu tout j'ai
rêvé comme toutes les femmes d'une
existence unique ou mais de voir ces
conflits sans que mon coeur pu sacrifier
la terre ici vous êtes chargé de me
démontrer l'impossible je ne sais pas ce
qui se serait passé avec un autre mais
le gouvernement sait que c'est fait je
voudrais pas remis ça a été la première
des valeurs dites vous vous souffrez ça
passe
oh j'ai eu tort en fait je pars c'est ce
que vous avez demi aux affaires
oublier un mode troll qui ne signifie
rien je ne crois pas qu'on trompiez vous
êtes trop jeune et trop sincère et au
fond vous apprécie la tendresse que j'ai
pu je pensais que vous n'attendiez que
notre petit fait ordinaire tenait
toujours la colère m'a pris quand vous
m'avez dit que non où allez-vous faire
des visites ont trouvé une de vos amis
est ce un bien grand plaisir une
nécessité absolue
dégagez vous s'il le faut
écrivez que votre mari est malade et
vous rester près de lui c'est bien
simple faites ce que je vous demande
rendez moi cette tournée qui
m'appartient depuis si longtemps et que
vous m'avez réservé jusqu'ici
je voudrais que je ne pourrais pas et
pourquoi est on vient me chercher en
voiture et l'on mène au moins vous
alliez sortie non c'est une erreur
j'attendais madame simpson
même si mme saule justement le dim cl au
col drôle d'homme vous êtes tous fage
même ce qui devrait vous rassurer
au modem sera c'est vrai je vous dis
yako madame simpson n'est pas de vos
ennemis et que vous avez voulu
m'interdire sa maison une maison
charmante monte supérieure nombreux
chats ya peut-être des amoureux je ne
dis pas ça comme partout madame simpson
a la plus mauvaise réputation tant pis
pour ceux qui l'avions fait quand un
homme a vu à une femme à bout de sa
chemise
cette femme est sacrée pour lui sacré
retenez bien ce principe mais qu'il vous
servent à l'occasion je suis et pouvant
que voulez vous je me demande où nous
allons est ce que vous vous préparez ce
record l'enfance la plus grave que
puisse entendre une femme vous venez me
la faire aujourd'hui
qu'est ce qui vous reste maintenant tu
ne vois plus que les violences en libye
que vous serez mètres de vous que vous
vous arrêterez en violences réfléchissez
à mon ami il vaudrait mieux ne s'est pas
fait tout de suite si vous deviez on y
revient là on voit cette fois très
sérieusement
voilà rassurés quelques horreurs que
vous ayez pour madame simpson vous
préférez encore me savoir avec nous
reprendrons cette idée de voyage
je vous y amènerait je l'espère la
première fois que je vous verrai demain
à demain
c'est donc changer maintenant vous
voulez bien matin au lendemain
soit je n'ai qu'une parole mais voyez
bien sûr vous vous êtes assez calme en
ce moment est bien résolue n'allait pas
changer de l'autre côté de la porte
vous avez l'escalier malheureux vous en
avertir si d'ici à deux ou même fait un
tout si je vous rencontre au bois wire
si j'aperçois le bout de votre joli né
quelque part vous ne me voyez de votre
vie
à demain à demain
alors il n'y a rien à dire il a été
raisonnable quand il se fâche c'est
plaisant mais j'ai toujours peur de voir
pleurer
assurons-nous avant de partir que je ne
l'aurais pas derrière moi et ça va
tristement la tête bat bon garçon
certainement je les ferai une petite
visite demain
qu'est ce qui lui prend il s'arrête
il revient sur ses pas il entre dans la
maison en face le monstre il va me tuer
et me tenir là jusqu'à ce qu'il tombe de
fatigue je vais lui montrer que je les
bûchers le seul moyen de le faire partir
à l'autre maintenant
a dole à dole qu'est ce que tu fais là
a dole réponse laisse moi je te prie
qu'est ce qui t'arrive en voilà une mine
pour rentrer chez soi même ne
connaissait pas encore l'appareil ne
mérite pas davantage je ne suis pas en
train de rire et d'écouté des gamineries
qu'est ce qu'il y a le sol
il ya ce sera toujours trop tôt
ces deux au sérieux un sérieux s'est
fâché serais tu as moins terracher
contre moi même j'ai pour toi de les
sortir seuls ça où vas-tu d'abord au
louvre maura achètent des chiffons le
moment est bien choisi posthume ennuis à
la fin on fait parler
on ne sort pas comme mon mari a de la
peine et que je ne sais pas ce que c'est
que cette peine
c'est la porte pour me le dire c'est
très bien j'attendrais aussi pour la
connaître
tu es bien gentil par le don bêta mais
nous sommes tombés à quel propos
auxquels propos pour l'heure seul c'est
ça comment toi un homme tu te mets dans
des états pareils et tu me révolutionne
par contrecoup pour une affaire qui n'a
pas marché
elle n'a pas marché voilà tout c'est
toujours ainsi les affaires l'une manque
l'autre réussi on profite de la bonne et
on oublie la mauvaise tu croyais
peut-être que j'allais me fâcher et de
faire des reproches
jamais mon cher ami remets toi et ne
gardent pas cette figure désormais
qu'est-ce que tu deviendras aiglons pour
un malheur véritable si c'est eux
perdaient par exemple à a
qu'est-ce qu'ils avaient raison un ton
oncle le joli protecteur que nous avons
là ne trouve rien ni ta situation était
écrit ni d'affamés finalement quand ils
s'occupent de quelque chose on peut être
sûr que ce sera fou je me demande
comment il a pu entrer à l'institut
je n'étais pas garçon ça me fait bien
rire alors dit moi un peu ce qui s'est
passé tu m'as tout dire je ne sais rien
je ne sais rien non plus c'est fini
n'est ce pas tout à fait fini un peu à
peu près seulement qu'est ce que ça
signifie à peu près la recette est elle
donnée oui ou non elle n'est pas encore
donné le faire la recette va être donnée
l'on m'a fait comprendre qu'elle ne
serait pas pour moi c'est bien voilà
renseignements et qui choisit to'ata
place un homme ordinaire je m'en doute
bien marié je me tuerai choc répond
toujours morieux oui ça femmes et jeunes
de ton âge je lis incroyable les jets
ont le dus à la matinée je te comprends
et n'étant dutronc ces choses là ne se
font jamais aux finances
en sortent personne n'est encore nommé
ni toi ni un londres était désespérée
trop tôt comme à ton habitude je ne veux
bien que faire au toit de la mémoire un
peu à l'est ce mois entendons-nous c'est
inutile j'écris à l'eau note et je lui
demande un rendez vous
elle comprendra qu'il s'agit d' affaire
sérieuse le lot
qu'est ce que c'est que ça le lot
galaxie madame simpson de l'aplomb la
lotte dans l'intimité ça lui fait
plaisir c'est bien écrire le loc
tu diras ce que tu voudras six lots lot
réussi là où un membre de l'institut a
échoué
j'en serais charme et pour ma part mais
je plaindre et la france l'est de la
france tant qu ils ne s'occupaient pas
d'elle elle ne s'occupe pas de toit et
occupe un petit quelque chose à faire en
ce moment j'ai l'intention de rester
chez moi une maison fermée pendant huit
jours
mais je ne veux pas j'ai pas envie tu de
désespère vous une affaire qui peut être
encore très bien tourné la prendre cette
lettre et la portée chez madame si ça se
promènera de la fira voir ton oncle
pourquoi un homme qui n'est bon à rien
tu le dis toi même
j'aime écrire mon nom que j'ai ainsi de
ses conseils étaient dispose de son
influence je ne veux on sait que ton
oncle s'est occupé d'une position pour
nous qui que ce soit qui ne l'obtiennent
ce sera toujours un lieu que nous la
devons
tu me comprends n'a pas envie qu'on dise
que madame simpson te protège et que
nous enlevons les faveurs grâce à elle
où elle son entourage c'est très juste
je vais les papes et j'aimerais voir mon
oncle mais les économistes se passe
moins cette fois je ne veux pas pourquoi
changer quelque chose à nos habitudes
c'est pas le gore fait pour toi ce dîner
j'en reviens généralement forte à la
tête assez en l'air avec des histoires
qui me donne un aperçu de vos
conversations quand vous êtes en train
de vous dire de bêtises
vous avez bien raison ne te prie pas
d'un plaisir va on en a pas tant ce
moule thuir a retrouvé ces messieurs
dont le genre tam
et moi ma petite amie qui serais désolé
de ne pas pouvoir
eh bien je n'insiste pas mais
aujourd'hui où je suis de très mauvaise
humeur j'aurais préféré rester avec toi
on te remercie ne le regrette pas sa se
retrouvera au revoir je lui portais
tablettes
c'est cela étonnant l'audois n'est ce
pas est un peu de gaieté si c'est
possible
ne mettons pas les autres dans la
confidence de nos ennuis ça ne sert à
rien
qu'est-ce que je dois dire à mon nous ce
que tu voudras voilà c'est bien convenu
tu m'envoies ce dîner tu me envoie dans
des dispositions atroce elles passeront
quand tu seras à table clément flanchec
jusque là
or par les dons de sagesse et de retenue
à une femme qu'elle reste dans sa maison
et sa maison prospèrera je tombe parce
qu'il aurait fait mon mari s'il ne
m'avait pas sans compter qu'on est
toujours bien disposés avec les honnêtes
gens toujours toujours quand il ya
quelque chose à donne une place une fois
saveurs grande petite et que deux
candidats sont en présence d'un côté un
bras vont pas bien formé modeste et viry
temps et de l'autre quelques farceurs
qui n'a pour lui que son savoir-faire
toujours c'est le farceur qui n'en porte
et le bond choqué blackboulé je finirai
peut-être pas ressortir aujourd'hui moi
j'espère que monsieur lafon ce sera
fatigué de m'attendre
il ne s'étonnera pas cette fois ci je le
dis ce temps pendant quelque temps
filant
[Musique]
c'est trop
vous m'en voulait d'être revenu voici ce
qui s'est passé je m'en allais je vous
le jure je ne voulais plus penser à vous
jusqu'à demain j'aperçois votre mari qui
rentrait que devait faire j'aurais été
très heureux de lui serrer la main mais
vous préfériez peut-être qu'il ignora ma
visite il était prudent alors de ne pas
montrer vous me dit toujours que je ne
tiens compte de rien quand quand je
passe ma vie avec adolphe a sauvé les
difficultés je me suis retournée
vivement pendant qu'il ne me voyais pas
que je suis entré sous une porte cochère
pour le laisser passer
il est bien rentré n'est ce pas vous
avez dû le voir je n'invente rien après
c'est vrai j'ai été faible
il ne fallait pas rester là je me suis
dit claudine attend depuis longtemps
madame simpson qui n'a pas l'air de
venir beaucoup si ses projets ne tenait
plus elle serait peut-être bien naissent
de me retrouver
vous ne pouvez pas m'en vouloir d'une
pensée bien tendres et bien modeste
votre mari est ressorti ça ne changerait
pas les choses il était en dehors de
toutes les combinaisons
j'ai regardé encore une fois si je
voyais la voiture de madame simpson
arrivé je n'ai rien vu venir et je suis
remonté au jeu je suis remonté en
tremblant je vous assure et je serais
sans doute redescendu sans un de ses
tout petits hasards qui sent souvent
drôle votre mari avait laissé la porte
ouverte
voyons clotilde il n'y a rien là que de
bien simple et de biens naturels on ne
se fâche pas pour si peu de chose a dit
ces mots vous ne voulez pas de dirhams
en un seul
c'est bien je vois que décidément vous
préférez avoir cette journée à vous je
vous laisse à demain à demain
vous ne voulez pas me dire un mot je
suis déçu je vous le déclare
depuis quelques temps vous me traitez
trop légèrement il sans aucune
considération pour le passé vous êtes
bien résolue à me répondre
et bien comme vous voudrez finissons-en
vous ne m'aimez plus je vous
embarrassent je n'ai plus de grandes
bien de bien grandes joies avec vous
quand je pourrai être heureux ailleurs
séparons nous séparons nous un jour
d'esprit
vous voulez que je vous dise nous attend
des personnes c'est votre amant vous
allez retrouver c'est avec louis devaux
dîner ce soir soutenait dans le
contraire je le connais je ne vous ai
pas dit son nom tout à l'heure c'est
monsieur l'ex merci alfred mercier
alfred halphen merci les rues de la
madeleine 28 boulevard de la madeleine
28 ans clotilde est ce une moquerie de
votre part ou bien c'est la vérité que
vous venez de m'avouer c'est bien la
vérité n'est ce pas ans clotilde
qu'est ce que vous venez de faire il
fallait me tromper délicatement semble
dire et sans que je le vois c'est bien
la fin cette fois ne sais pas c'est bien
la fin adieu
adieu
[Applaudissements]
voilà j'ai bien voulu être complaisantes
et me prêtait à une explication
tintin mais tous les jours deux fards à
joues non non non nous réd l'agrément
avec des passions pareil qui ne vous
laisse pas le temps de respirer sans
compter qu'on est toujours un deux
doivent une catastrophe c'est vrai je ne
suis plus tranquille que comme mon mari
est là
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
monsieur simpson madame vous faites
comme chez votre mère n'est ce pas vous
servir et oui mal à porter cette tasse à
monsieur et madame n'aura plus besoin de
moi non j'avais prévenu
ça tombe bien brève quitter paris
décidément décidé aujourd'hui même je
prends le train de 7 heures qui me
mettrai à minuit chez moi au mal ça fait
mon job et cycles et termine en ce
moment le reste si peu de temps vraiment
que je craindrais de vous déranger comme
vous voudrez
c'est ce que pense votre mère dans cette
brusque e résolution même est enchanté
de me voir partir oui c'est un peu pour
elle que je m'en vais plutôt l'habitude
elle m'a demandé d'en inspecter sa
propriété de fond en comble et de
diriger les réparations qui seront
nécessaires je veux que ma mère ne
reconnaissent pas croquignol quand elle
viendra s'y installer votre père est de
votre côté
je n'ai plus rien à d vous aimez tant
paris vous ne mettez pas qu'on s'y
trouvent mal et qu'on puisse vivre
ailleurs il pense pas ça je les trouve
seulement qu'à vos trajets dans votre
situation
un homme n'abandonne pas parie
volontiers surtout s'ils y étaient
retenues par le plus léger rattachement
l'hiver est à peine fini le temps et
offre personne ne songe encore à partir
excepté vous il faut que vous ayez une
raison j'en avais une plutôt pour rester
alors pourquoi vous en avez vous je
m'ennuie je suis irrité et humilié je me
fais l'effet d'un pauvre dans votre pari
qu'est ce que c'est que ce misérable
autres sauf je demeure géo pour moi de
l'invité et c'est bien piquante ont fait
le plaisir de venir me voir ma mère se
refuse toujours à me donner un intérieur
comme je le voudrais elle préfère quand
je voyage je dépense beaucoup d'argent
sans en tirer les plaisirs ni honneur là
bas à croquignol le décor change je mène
grand train
je compte dans le pays on me salue très
bas quand je passe
j'ai sous la main tout ce qui me manque
ici mais je vous mets chien mais fut si
vous savez que j'ai une magnifique
collection de fusil qu'il me tarde
toujours un peu de retrouver en bonne
état pareil est agréable évidemment et
je me plierai peut-être autres canaux si
j'y adhère dans des conditions qui
satisferait mon amour propre mais pas si
vous consoler et vous concerne
ce kit est comme nous le faisons de
gaieté de coeur après quatre mois c'est
vraiment le temps ne vous aura pas paru
non respect seul mois croyez-vous canton
15 janvier 15 février 15 mars et reste
maître cinq mois n'en parlons plus vous
devriez venir cet été a continué quand
ma mère sera là avec une partie de sa
société ne comptez pas sur moi mon mari
ne peut pas s'absenter si aisément vous
le laisseriez n'aime pas ça et vous vous
retrouveriez avec votre amie madame
beaulieu que les difficultés n'arrête
pas là pour l'hymne cet autre chose elle
a une fortune d'abord qui nous permet de
faire ce qu'elle veut et puis son mari a
eu le grand tort avec elle elle en
profite elle a bien raison
elle s'amuse madame beaulieu je m'en
sers ville nous sommes très liés avec
pauline très liés mais nous ne nous
disons pas tout c'étaient les
supporteurs qui vous a mise en relation
avec ma mère pauline n'a jamais su
pourquoi je le désirais qu'est ce qui
vous fait penser que madame beaulieu ne
se conduisent pas régulièrement vous dit
quelque chose sur elle je lui connaît
une forte tokat pour atmea me vous
l'appelez hector de godefroy c'était à
peine un secret madame beaulieu vous ne
pouvez pas l'ignorer vit depuis des
années avec un garçon charmant qui ne la
quitte jamais qu'il adore oui mais
madame beaulieu s'est amouraché je peux
tout le monde pourquoi de mon ami hector
ne passe plus un jour sans gloire mais
je vous dis que madame beaulieu est très
lié avec ce jeune homme et il se nomme
alfred merci
voilà ce que j'apprécie encore en
m'éloignant de paris mon en terre tas
d'histoires qui ne sont pas bien
pourquoi c'est pour mon ami je crois
qu'elle comprendre sa part paul il a
bien souffert l'ennemi par higuain
aujourd'hui je l'avais peut-être fait la
qualité ne m'en serais jamais venu au
ras le bol il est tout bonnement
adorable je n'aime pas un être confondu
avec tout le monde
il faut cependant bien faisait attendre
un peu les femmes ne serait pas contente
si elle vous entendez est-ce que ça
prouve nous sommes faibles changeantes
faut pas bon si vous les voulez que nous
nous laissons entraîner toujours que
nous rencontrons des malades rock qui ne
nous aiment pas comme nous le voudrions
ou des ingrats ski et puis les noms de
l'estimé de l'affection que pour
eux-mêmes vous avez raison du reste le
mieux serait de ne connaître ni les uns
et les autres de se fermer les yeux de
se boucher les oreilles de se dire
courageusement ta place et leur reste ou
si la vie ne serait peut-être pas très
drôle ni très palpitante mais ont suivi
très bien des tracas bien des déceptions
c'est bien des regrets
que vais vous
c'est vous pleurait et bien ça fait un
mot je vous laisse
pourquoi pleurer vous ma chère et
français il ya un peu de tout dans les
larmes une femme je serais désolé que
mon départ mais on ne vous fait pas plus
coupables que vous ne l'êtes
on se rend compte qu'on se plaît on se
sait pas c'est l'histoire de tous les
jours mais messieurs vous êtes bien
accommodant pour obtenir les bonnes
grâces est bien sévère quand nous les
avons accordé
il faut que j'appelle mon mari qui nous
laisse la seule jusqu'à demain avec sa
bonne foi cette sublime ignorance de
toutes nos folies dites-moi a lieu gardé
de ces cinq mois un bon souvenir c'est
tout ce que je demande gardez le pour
vous seul comme vous lever et comme je
peux m'y attendre de votre part c'est à
vous que nous devons d'avoir réussi dans
ce que nous désirions mais le service
n'est venu qu'après la faute et il
n'était pas nécessaire si vous voulez un
jour en passant me serrer la main au
collet c'est maintenant la maison où
vous avez fait tout ce qu'il faut pour
être bien
vous êtes charmante
il s'est alors attends tu as ces fumées
adolphe tu m'entends tu finiras toujours
non un autre jour monsieur c'est une
somme proche un chapeau hier soit vite
si tu veux descendre avec lui on allait
bien je me conduis comme bad a pris avec
vous je vous inventez ça ne fait rien
j'ai pris cette habitude après le
déjeuner de me reposer un instant c'est
le seul moment où je me sens bien chez
moi vous êtes frais quand vous voudrez
partons alors vous permettez que je dise
un mot à ma femme certainement est-ce
qu'il faut que je remercie ce jeune
homme
non nous l'avons invité à déjeuner ça
suffit nous devons beaucoup
son ami du ministère c'est sa mère qui a
tout fait depuis que je lui ai envoyé un
mot devant toi tu te souviens je ne
savais pas que madame simpson avait un
fils de cet âge là pas mal trouves-tu
distingué mais bien grand emprunt ça ne
me déplaît pas qu'est ce qu'il te disais
que j'étais parfaite au moral au
physique aussi je suis bon enfant de
vous avoir léché ensemble il part ce
soir elle peut revenir n'est pas encore
celui là qui me fera oublier mes devoirs
vous voudrez bien m'excuser madame de me
retirer si vite
je sais que votre temps est compté vous
me l'avez dit et je n'ose pas obtenir
je regrette déjà paris avant d'avoir
quitté vous allez l'oublier bien
facilement ma mère on verra bientôt sans
doute t elle me donnera de vos nouvelles
je lui demanderons aussi des veaux
rappelez vous que vous êtes attendus à
croquignol il n'est pas probable que
vous me voyez je ne me tiens pas pour
battus si une occasion se présente pour
moi de venir à paris ni au besoin je la
prenne être j'essaierai encore de vous
décider
ne venez pas pour m'inviter mais pour me
voir
à bientôt alors à bientôt
parce que je te disais qu'à tchernobyl
après le saut a battu tous ces jeunes au
jour d'aujourd'hui ne valent pas la
peine qu'on s'occupe de ses sacs plein
de prétention je ne crois rien les aime
la peau et voilà tout respect avec
monsieur simpson élevé par sa mère
s'attacherait sérieusement à une femme
mais pas à me plaindre de lui du reste
il a toujours été fort convenable les
trésors religieux c'est un peu bête avec
ses fusils
c'est bien fait pour moi j'avais tout ce
qu'il me fallait un ami excellent un
second mari autant dit il est malmené de
toutes les manières il en a eu assez et
ça se comprend
qui sait me croient peut-être plus fâché
que je ne suis les hommes ne connaît si
peu
nous sommes bien faible c'est vrai avec
celui qui nous plaît mais nous revenons
toujours à celui qui nous est celui-là
faune madame le bukut avait tonné bon
dans ces messieurs la fournissons le
recevoir
certainement vous pouvez vous en allez
maintenant appel si vous avez besoin de
sortir
[Applaudissements]
bonjour
ou sur mon ami commente allegri
doucement doucement et vous mal très mal
je vous dérange un peu moins de mots
vous alliez sortir peut-être à fois non
je sors à peine maintenant oui mais vous
aviez du monde à déjeuner du monde non
une personne un ami impasse vaut le
nommer mon mari me l'a dit mais je m'en
souviens je viens de les voir partir
ensemble devrait vous étiez là sous les
fleurs si vous l'avez si je me serais
montre un instant très gentil de votre
part au moins vous ne m'avez pas oublier
tout de suite qu'elle est et ce monsieur
passons je vous le répète le premier
venu il ne peux pas vous donner de l'eau
grrrr mon mari me l'a présenté ce matin
ce soir il sera parti
vous me dites la vérité pourquoi vous
mentirais maintenant vous ne changez pas
c'est une justice a beau se démener
cédant scouts et tenez vous ici c'est
possible je ne vois pas voit pas agiter
homé marché quand votre foi m'avait
laissé le meilleur souvenir
clope il n'y a pas eu de clash on a mis
un peu de calme n'est ce pas ne nous
égarons pas assez vite
j'ai bien regretter à les sept scènes
ridicules que vous pouviez empêcher si
facilement regardez moi monsieur alfred
mercier mais que voulez-vous j'étais
jaloux depuis longtemps de ce monsieur
merci et tous les soupçons se portaient
sur lui
madame beaulieu ne se plaindra pas de
votre discrétion c'est bien ce que vous
avez fait que je ne vous ai vus j'ai
pensé à vous ça se disent après après
j'ai vécu comme d'habitude ne vous est
pas absente et il fallait me déplacer je
n'en ai pas eu le courage ces
demoiselles ont-elles été gracieusement
el biar su je ne vous répond pas
pourquoi il est possible qu autrefois
une infidélité de votre part du tt
sensible très sensible qu'est ce qui
vous était défendue alors vous êtes bien
permis maintenant avec cela que je ne
vous connais pas que vous êtes un homme
avoue passer de consolation si vous
n'étiez pas toujours bien aimable mon
ami est bien dit et bien confirmée mais
pardon pas ces choses là
je souffre beaucoup trop je vous assure
pour songer à vous remplacer dans un
monde que je ne fréquente plus vous avez
vous devriez retourner auprès de ces
dames sont libres on ne se gêne pas avec
elle aime les histoires l'écrivain avoue
ne trouvera jamais ça avec nous mais
nous pouvons vous donner que l'affection
paisible ça se désintéresse
mais c'est ce que je demande c'est ce
que nous demandons tous
alors mon ami il ne fallait pas risquer
ce que vous teniez pour le plaisir de
faire un coup de tête
clotilde quoi mon ami donnez moi votre
main non
vous pouvez bien me donner votre main de
tard ne prenez pas cette ère l'homme
vous renvoie à l'instant 20 donnez moi
votre main tenait la voici
[Rires]
fall autres maintenant vous êtes bien
froide
comment froid ve je vous fait asseoir
près de moi je vous permet d'embrasser
vous ne pensiez pas que j'allais me
jeter à votre cou dès que vous entriez
je suis là comme un coupable
j'accepte tous les reproches comme vous
le faites nous en meritorious aussi
aucun presse ma faute ou la vôtre
sinon rapports ont été changés tout d'un
coup il n'y avait pas d'homme plus
heureux que moi jusqu'au jour où votre
existence a été bouleversé qu'est ce que
vous vous dites mon existence
bouleversée elle ne pouvait l'être peu
par vous si je ne vous avais pas arrêtée
à temps mais vous avez raison je ne sais
pas pourquoi je reviens là dessus
laissons ce qui s'est passé qu'est ce
qui s'est passé vous est incorrigible
je vous reçois je vous écoute je crois
que vous regrettez sincèrement une
conduite inexplicable je me dis que plus
tard peut-être si vous pourrez formiez
sérieusement il ne serait pas impossible
que je vous pardonne et voilà que vous
me fâcher encore avec ce mauvais
explique que je déteste en vous et que
je n'ai jamais réussi à vaincre il s'est
rien passé vu que vous entendez bien
viendra viendra pas seulement car
éloignés pourquoi eloignez-vous ce désir
ne vais bien me laisser me levais vous
ne partez pas encore continuer je suis
nerveux et agité par raison plus vous
dites je viens de l'appel mon chum de
migraine on ne vous trouble et pas je ne
lui resterait à 6 vous songez donc un
thème donné ça tutoz reprenons notre
bonne existence d'autrefois coilbault
serait jamais heureux avec moi je ne
serai jamais tranquille avec vous ne
voulez pas comprendre ma situation que
situation n'a situation parce que je
n'ai pas de mari dont je dépends un
tiers moi qui dois me trouver là toutes
les fois qu'il le désire c'est bien le
moins vous l'avouerez voilà encore une
de biens de vos biens grande faute à mon
égard et que vous vous éviteriez si vous
me connaissiez
qu'est ce que vous me reprochez vous
n'aimez pas mon âge
merci mais si je vous assure je vous le
garantis vous n'aimez pas à gueule ça
que je le vois bien des choses sont
peut-être vos caractères qui ne
s'accorde bien la position qui veut sauf
quelle injustice votre mari il n'a que 2
a mis au monde deux à wii 2 l'éclair
vous c'est moi et sont les autres de
côté ne parlons que de nous soyez
sincère claudine
est-il vrai que vous me plaisier ça oui
je crois que je suis à votre goût une
affection comme la mienne ne se
rencontre pas tous les jours est ce que
vous emmenez qu'on va certainement c'est
bien parce qu'elle me touche et que j'en
tiens compte que j'ai supporté toutes
vos tempête je suis bien doux
d'ordinaire bien tendres même des
panneaux vous savez parfaitement clair
quand vous le voulez bien vous dit
quelquefois de faux jolies choses qui
sont très agréables et baveux qui parle
de riez de fusil à une femme mais qu'est
ce que ça veut dire qu'il ya une sottise
convaincante et de pardon
vous dites moi vous me pardonnez nous
tourmenter page irez vous voir bientôt
quand vous voudrez prenez garde on ne
suit pas ce qu'ils clotilde tu mènes je
t'adore
au nord on nous dit des paroles inutiles
pour nous retrouver au même point les
regrettez-vous pas d'accord j'étais bien
triste en venant ici je vous quitterai
dans de meilleures dispositions que
cette petite leçon vous profite plus de
ce n est ce pas plus de ces affreux
soupçons qui désobligeantes une femme et
qui sont inutiles
si quelque chose ne va pas vous fait de
la peine dites le moi je suis toujours
disposé à entendre raison
écoutez je vais vous dire une nouvelle
qui ne vous déplaira pas voyons je crois
que mes beaux jours avec madame simpson
sont finis bah oui vous avez eu à vous
plaindre d'elle non je n'ai eu qu'à me
louer des lots contraire ce n'est pas
précisément madame simpson que je ne
veux plus voir si sa maison
oui me paraît préférable de ne pas aller
qu'est ce que je vous avais dit tout de
suite vous êtes plus fin que moi voilà
tout je connais une autre personne dont
la société n'est pas bien bonne pour
vous et que vous devriez écarté aussi
vous allez me dire une bêtise je vois ça
dit si cette personne c'est madame
beaulieu one trash eric pauline je
voudrais bien savoir pourquoi pourquoi
pas il me semble qu est ce qui pousse en
monsieur merchier monsieur mercier
j'ai appris ce qu'il en est ce que vous
savez bien aussi oui je le sais après à
vous ne défendez pas madame beaulieu je
présume ça pensez vous un peu ce que
vous me dites est ce que vous allez
reprocher à madame beaulieu de faire
pour monsieur mercier ce que je fais
pour vous mais ce n'est pas la même
chose
expliquez moi la différence à jean bouin
sucre à la crème
mais voyons après laquelle vous êtes
tous les mêmes monsieur pour vous nous
pouvons tous nous permet mais vous vous
révoltez quand ce sont les autres tirent
profit plutôt que de vous occuper de
pauline vous feriez mieux de songer à
mon mari qui a demandé tous les jours
pourquoi on ne vous voyait plus et qui
va vous demander des explications hans
et adolphe eux que nous venons
d'entendre rentrée oui cet add-on
avez-vous pensez un peu à ce que vous
lui diriez non ça vous fait rire mais
tant pis pour vous mon ami vous vous
direz de la com vous pourrez
bonjour mon cher ou jours pourquoi
n'at-on pas vu depuis si longtemps
comment vas-tu je me porte à merveille
tu ne réponds pas à ma question que
s'est il donc passé que tu es disparu du
jour au lendemain ne tourne pas il a eu
un gros chagrin
n'est ce pas monsieur lafon oui madame
quel chagrin est-ce qu'il faut que je
dise à mon mari et si vous voulez madame
bardot
il était jaloux janou commenté encore
jaloux un tournage
et d'utiliser des jalons d'une femme qui
ne lui appartient pas bien entendu ces
célibataires ils ne se refuse rien ils
sont jaloux par dessus le marché
petit falise l'opinion d'un économiste
célèbre sur la jalousie la jalousie
c'est la privation pas autre chose
si tu étais marié d'une sphère privée et
est ce que tu lui as dit quoi dont que
j'ai été nommé sur la foi et le premier
kit est écrit pour te féliciter en effet
je ne m'en souvenais plus il m'a écrit
plutôt que de venir me voir
c'est mon hautement vieux bonhomme donc
qui a relevé cette affaire là on sait
bien c'est ton nom que tu n'as pas
besoin de le crier sur les toits et bien
est ce que ça ne vaut pas renié d'être
receveur que d'être jaloux un peu pauvre
la faune il est pas encore permis il n'a
pas sonné ordinaire à sa tête aller
tromper ou n'est-elle pas trompé laisse
moi dans quoi tu peux bien me dire ça à
moi tu appelles propre et où ne
t'appelles pas trompé mon mari vous
faites une question répond daisy que
voulez vous que je réponde
il y at il un homme un seul qui jurait
que sa maîtresse ne l'a pas trompé
la mienne m'a dit que non elle ne
pouvait pas me dire oui nous sommes
réconciliés c'est sans doute ce que nous
désirions l'un et l'autre vraiment il
est bien fâcheux que cette dame ne soit
pas ici pour vous entendre
elle servait l'opinion vous avez d'elle
et de toutes les femmes la confiance
monsieur lafon la confiance voilà le
seul système qui réussissent avec nous''
a toujours été le mien cher
la pièce que nous venons de jouer devant
vous et de henri bec
le décor de roger à
les costumes de donald port douala
[Applaudissements]
et la mise en scène de rené clément
avec claudine collard
question à l'air
bernard alane
dominique paturel
et micheline boudet
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]